je le disais en début d'édition un
Egypte Gasmi est avec nous en plateau
pour parler de la semaine d'éducation
contre le racisme et l'antisémitisme
votre association
œil à pic a été sélectionné dans le
cadre d'un appel à projet de l'État sur
le sujet vous proposez en ce moment une
exposition au collège de Gassicourt de
Mantes-la-Jolie c'est jusqu'au 30 mars
elle a été créée par les enfants et les
jeunes que vous accompagnez sont noms
peut-être voir l'affiche de cette
exposition c'est à l'école du vivre
ensemble voilà on voit la fiche de cette
exposition qui sont justement ces jeunes
que vous avez accompagné qui ont
participé à la création de de cette
exposition en fait dans le dans le
travail qui est mené par l'association
EIA px c'est que de janvier à partir de
janvier jusqu'à fin mars on travaille
sur les thématiques autour de ladykra du
vivre ensemble et du faire ensemble
parce qu'il ne suffit pas de dire qu'on
vit ensemble pour que tout soit bien sûr
donc il faut aussi faire ensemble donc
ce sont les gels qu'on accueille dans le
cas de l'accompagnement à la scolarité
sur des de 16h30 à 18h pour les
primaires et de 18h15 à 19h30 pour les
collégiens et lycéens donc c'est un
travail qui est fait au fur et à mesure
des séances donc avec un temps sur la
première demi-heure autour de tout ce
qui est travail scolaire donc revoir un
petit peu l'organisation comment ça se
passe au niveau de l'école parce que il
suffit pas de dire sur ton cahier de
texte ou on va voir ce que tu as à faire
on va prendre la température de la
journée donc on commence toujours à sur
un moment pour prendre
avec eux comment ça s'est comment s'est
passé la journée et ensuite on commence
à avoir des échanges avec eux sur un
petit peu ce qu'il pense du racisme de
la discrimination de l'antisémitisme et
on travaille avec eux sur comment eux
voient les choses et c'est important à
cet âge-là justement de les éduquer sur
sur le sujet de parler de ces sujets qui
sont très importants avec des faits
d'actualité on parle souvent de racisme
d'antisémitisme dans l'actualité c'est
important de les évoquer des sujets avec
les jeunes c'est très important c'est
aussi une éducation à quelque chose donc
l'idée c'est vraiment des amener à
s'approprier un certain nombre de deux
choses un vocabulaire mais aussi à
s'ouvrir vers les autres ce n'est pas
parce que on se retrouve dans des
classes un petit peu
avec de l'entre-soi qu'on doit pas être
amené à rencontrer d'autres personnes
donc d'où l'idée de les sortir de créer
cet évêque donc de l'éveil à la culture
d'une part mais aussi autour de cette
thématique qui sont très sensibles et on
se saisit d'une semaine thématique mais
en fait ce travail il est fait tout au
long de l'année voilà donc c'est et
c'est ça qui est important c'est
vraiment de faire ce travail au long
cours pour permettre à ce qui
s'approprie à certains nombre de choses
mais aussi de créer du débat de créer de
la discussion de construire les préjugés
à l'orage des préjugés comme tout le
monde
on n'est pas parce qu'on habite dans un
quartier sensible qu'on a moins de
préjugés que les autres on en a autant
que les jeunes de Versailles ou de 50
ans on en a autant donc c'est comment
est-ce qu'on amène justement ces
différents publics à se rencontrer et à
travailler ensemble et à faire les
choses ensemble régime vie également le
fait que vous ayez ces ateliers en fin
de journée ça leur permet aussi de
s'exprimer ce que c'est important pour
pour vous de leur donner la parole et
d'apprendre justement exprimer leur
opinion c'est très important pour nous
qui puisse s'approprier et prendre la
parole donc c'est un ils apprennent à
s'exprimer à respecter l'autre respecter
la parole de l'autre à savoir prendre la
parole on les prépare au bac de demain
enfin d'aujourd'hui puisqu'ils étaient
depuis hier en passage d'examen au
niveau du bac donc c'est vraiment cette
oralité qui leur permet aussi de
s'approprier à certains ou deux choses
et de prendre confiance en eux puisque
il n'y a pas de bonne ou mauvaise
réponse il n'y a pas de bonne ou
mauvaise idée c'est vraiment comment
est-ce qu'on arrive à un moment donné à
donner sur l'opinion à donner son avis
et aussi à pouvoir s'exprimer en public
on parle de vivre ensemble c'est le nom
de l'exposition c'est la solution pour
vous le vivre ensemble bien vivre
ensemble même sur sur cette thématique
la solution elle est elle est diverses
et variée moi le vivre ensemble je enfin
on vit tous ensemble enfin je voilà il y
a pas de souci
mais c'est pour ça que je parle du faire
ensemble et elle est là la différence
c'est dire que on est sur un territoire
comment ta jolie on est tous ensemble
sur le territoire maintenant c'est
comment est-ce que sur ce territoire on
fait ensemble les choses pour amener à
ce qu'il y ait une bonne connaissance
des uns et des autres une bonne le
respect des uns et des autres et comment
est-ce qu'on travaille ensemble pour que
demain on est cette possibilité de voir
la société évoluer vers le bien
aujourd'hui quand on va ce qui se passe
au niveau
des chaînes d'information on continue
etc et tout ce qu'on nous rabâche à
longueur de journée j'ai pas
l'impression qu'on est qu'on souhaite
qui est ce vivre ensemble donc nous tout
le travail c'est vraiment d'amener les
jeunes à avoir cet esprit critique
pour pouvoir justement dire ah oui mais
là ils sont en train de dire ça mais
c'est pas ça qui se passe en réalité
quand on envoie des enfants du Val
Fourré au Lycée Militaire de Saint-Cyr
pour qu'ils puissent continuer à
scolarité ou à l'internat d'excellence
de Marly Leroy
les jeunes ont souvent des préjugés en
disant ouais on va dans un lycée
militaire ils vont pas nous accepter et
cetera mais les jeunes de du Val Fourré
aussi des préjugés en disant ouais de
toute façon c'est des fils de militaires
ou des fils entre guillemets de de
fonctionnaires donc pareil ils vont pas
nous accepter et quand vous avez un
jeune qui vous dit aujourd'hui mes
meilleurs amis sont ceux de Saint-Cyr
bah le vivre ensemble on y arrive et le
faire ensemble surtout puisque là du
coup on fait ensemble on y arrive et ça
permet aussi de créer de vrais
passerelles on a vu des images de
l'exposition il y a différents supports
qui sont visibles différents projets
finalement qui est réalisé l'idée de
cette exposition c'est c'est vraiment
d'amener les les jeunes à voir qu'il
existe différents personnes qui se sont
battus pour cette égalité
au niveau de l'histoire que ce soit Rosa
Park ou d'autres quand on parle de
racisme dans le sport quand on voit
enfin des sportifs de haut niveau
handicapé qu'on a du mal à accepter
parce que ils ont cette différence donc
on est dans la discrimination par
rapport à un handicap donc c'est
vraiment d'amener les jeunes à avoir
cette ouverture et cette image positive
sur le territoire mais aussi sur au
niveau de la France et par la même on
travaille sur les valeurs de la
République liberté égalité fraternité et
ce sont des mots qui ont toute leur
importance dans l'accompagnement qui est
fait au quotidien elle est visible juste
par les collégiens et les équipes
pédagogiques tout le monde peut venir la
voir en fait tout le monde peut venir la
voir on a eu des moments de des mamans
qui sont venus hier pour la visiter
excellent excellent parce que ça permet
aussi de rendre visible le travail qui
est fait par les jeunes et les moins
jeunes et du coup c'est aussi ça permet
aussi d'échanger
avec les jeunes sur le travail qui a été
fait et bien bravo pour ce projet de
l'association eapiq je rappelle une
Égypte gasmique que vous en êtes le
président est donc cette exposition
visible au collège de Gassicourt à
Mantes-la-Jolie jusqu'au 30 mars le nom
de cette exposition c'est à l'école du
vivre ensemble